[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten abend
wenn es einen zeitpunkt gibt an dem der
kanzler in spe olaf scholz umstrittene
entscheidungen treffen kann ohne dass es
in der partei laut rumort dann jetzt
alle sind immer noch im glücksrausch
keiner will den amtsantritt des
spd-kanzlers mit nörgeleien vermiesen
das kommt noch früh genug die kritik
bereitschaft der sozialdemokraten
gegenüber ihren führungsleuten ist ja
legendär und tiefen der dna der partei
verankert der aktuelle schmusekurs wird
sich nicht verewigen doch im moment ist
genosse olaf quasi unantastbar
und so hat scholz bei der auswahl seiner
ministerinnen und minister auch keine
überraschung gescheut einige gingen leer
aus mit denen viele fest gerechnet
hatten und einer kam zum zug auf den
viele er nicht gewettet hätten andreas
ruppert berichtet
wer wird was bei den sozis die frage der
letzten tage ein gut gehütetes partei
geheimnis wenn es um die künftigen
bundesministerinnen und minister der spd
minuten vor der bekanntgabe werden noch
stand markierungen geklebt und die
journalistenschar rätselt immer noch
okay bk für bundeskanzler das ist klar
aber wer bitte bekommt das g für das
gesundheitsministerium als olaf scholz
die riege der künftigen minister herein
führt ist dieses geheimnis gelüftet denn
zum vorschein kommt auch der der wie
kein zweiter in der spd den kampf gegen
die korona pandemie ausgerufen hat
haben sich anders kann man das gar nicht
sagen bestimmt die meisten bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes gewünscht dass
der nächste gesundheitsminister vom fach
ist das wirklich gut kann und dass er
karl lauterbach heißt er wird es dabei
war die personalie lauterbach in der
parteispitze lange umstritten nicht
teamfähig so ein urteil doch die basis
machte druck wollte ihren part wer da in
die welt setzt dass er nicht teamfähig
ist oder dass man nicht auf ihn hört der
hat bewusst auch falsche dinge gestreut
ich freue mich darüber dass noch mal
dass unsere minister minister und
speziell karl lauterbach dass der eine
so große unterstützung haben inhaltliche
fragen an carl lauterbach gab es auch
gleich wie sieht's aus mit corona
weihnachten und dem reisen doch der
künftige kanzler bremst seinen künftigen
minister schließlich ist man ja noch
nicht im amt
was im vordergrund jetzt natürlich
stehen muss dass wir in den wochen die
wir noch haben die fallzahlen so stark
absenken dass wir möglichst gute
weihnachtsferien feiern können neben
neuling lauterbach sind auch altgediente
im ersten kabinett scholz svenja schulze
wechselt vom umweltressort ins
entwicklungsministerium
hubertus heil bleibt arbeits und
sozialminister eine überraschung war die
berufung von christine lambrecht sie
tauschen nämlich dass justiz mit dem
verteidigungsministerium neu auf der
bundespolitischen bühne und das auch
überraschend ist nancy faeser als erste
frau wird sie das innenministerium
leiten ein politikfeld dass sie schon in
hessen beackert hat
ein besonderes anliegen wird mir seien
die größte bedrohung die derzeit unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
hat den rechtsextremismus zu bekämpfen
auch klara geywitz ist minister novizin
sie war die frau an scholz seite die mit
ihm den kampf um den spd-vorsitz vor
zwei jahren verloren hat die
brandenburgerin wird im neu geschaffenen
bauministerium vorstehen die aufgabe die
vor uns liegt es riesig 400.000
wohnungen davon 100.000 gefördert zu
bauen jährlich das ist eine
herausforderung und
einer wäre da noch wolfgang schmidt
weggefährte strippenzieher im
hintergrund und engster vertrauter von
olaf scholz wenig überraschen wird er
chef des kanzleramtes und ich will dafür
sorgen dass olaf scholz den rücken frei
hat da wird er das machen kann was er
versprochen hat ordentlich zu regieren
bis mittwoch müssen sich die
sozialdemokraten allerdings noch
gedulden bis ihr olaf regieren darf erst
dann soll er vom bundestag zum kanzler
gewählt werden
die freude darüber wird bei den
sozialdemokraten zweifellos überwiegend
theo koll aber enttäuschte gab es heute
schon auch
absoluten spd teil des kabinetts ist ja
nur eine einzige frau aus dem osten im
ganzen kabinett sind es mit klara
geywitz und der grünen steffi lemke
insgesamt nur zwei ost vertreterin dabei
werden durchaus auch männer aus dem
osten wie carsten schneider ministrabel
gewesen oder scholz hat insgesamt die
ansonsten den parteien so wichtigen
regionalen kriterien weitgehend
ignoriert hessen ist stark vertreten
andere bundesländer dagegen gar nicht
und weitgehend ignoriert hat er auch
traditionelle links rechts kriterien was
man als beleg für seine aktuelle stärke
innerhalb der spd werten kann er hat
sich ein ziemliches scholz team
zusammengestellt menschen wie arbeits
und sozialminister hubertus heil oder
auch der künftige kanzleramtsminister
wolfgang schmidt sind langjährige
weggefährten auf die er sich unbedingt
verlassen kann das ist sehr stolz stil
karl lauterbach fällt er aus dem rahmen
ja dass der tatsächlich
gesundheitsminister wird damit hat er ja
auch nicht jeder gerechnet
absolut denn die die liste der vor
lauter war es kritikern vorgebrachten
gegenargumente war eben auch recht lang
das ja keine erfahrung habe ein so
großes ministerium zu führen dass er in
britta einzelgänger sei er unberechenbar
dass er probleme habe sich unterzuordnen
und nicht zu vergessen auch lauterbach
hatte sich um den spd vorsitz beworben
damals und massiv die große koalition
kritisiert und damit natürlich die
spd-parteispitze und olaf scholz all das
führte zu einer eher geringen
politischen wettquote für lauterbach
aber selten waren für ein minister
fachkenntnisse so wichtig wie in dieser
pandemie und da ist der arzt und
gesundheitsexperte lauterbach natürlich
weit fahren das heißt er ist im stoff
aber das heißt auch er muss von tag eins
an liefern dankeschön für die
einschätzung aus berlin dass bei der
postenvergabe des einen freud des
anderen leid ist haben die grünen auch
schon erfahren erst die enttäuschung
vieler in der partei darüber dass die
verhandler nicht das verkehrsministerium
eroberten und dann besonders bei der
parteilinken die enttäuschung dass der
bisherige fraktionschef anton hofreiter
leer ausgehen und ihm hätte es einen
fachmann sowohl für das verkehrs als
auch fürs land wirtschafts ressort
gegeben aber bei der besetzung von
kabinettsposten des expertise
bekanntlich ja nur ein faktor von vielen
und nicht unbedingt der ausschlaggebende
ein bisschen wie beim kinderspiel reise
nach jerusalem es gibt immer zu wenig
stören bei allem ärger abgesegnet hat
die grüne basis den koalitionsvertrag
heute trotzdem aus berlin thomas
reichert
auf den weg zurück an die macht stehen
sich die grünen an diesem nachmittag
mal kurz selbst den weg
klar man kann sich auch einreden ist ein
choreographie oder das votum der
mitglieder die 86 prozent für den
koalitionsvertrag angeblich ein mega
ergebnis
aus der urabstimmung in eine starke neue
bundesregierung starken gegenwind aber
gab es auch dass nicht die
kanzlerkandidatin baerbock sondern nun
harbeck vizekanzler wird haben die
beiden im frühjahr unter sich ausgemacht
was nach der wahl trotzdem für ärger in
der partei sorgte mit dem basisvotum
sind die spitzen grünen deshalb zuerst
mal 1 erleichtert
einmal luft holen kann und doch
zufrieden fast stolz auf den
koalitionsvertrag und auf das was wir
geleistet haben
auch wenn der bei weitem nicht alle
grünen wünsche erfüllt die grünen
bekommen nicht das verkehrsministerium
kein tempolimit stattdessen streiten
sich linke oder realos hofreiter und ist
mir zwischendurch um ein ministeramt
wenn man in situationen wo es nur
begrenzte anzahl von möglichen posten
gibt zwischen vielen klugen köpfen
auswählen muss dann ist das nicht
einfach das war auch für uns als partei
nicht einfach und wir leben ruckelt es
dann auch eine
parteiliste mir wurde so viele ämter
gehandelt dass landwirtschaftsminister
er nicht nun wird er der erste
vegetarier am tierschützer und anwalt
der bauern wichtiger noch der erste
bundesminister mit türkischem
migrationshintergrund
wir sind jetzt nicht an der wiege
gesungen worden dass ich eines tages mal
minister dieses landes werde insofern
empfinde ich auch die verantwortung
dafür ich weiß ein fehler den ich mache
ist ein fehler den haben stellvertretend
für sie die ganzen menschen
unterschiedlicher herkunft mitgebracht
sofern weiß ich um die rolle die ich
dann doch sophie sich die grünen auch
vorgenommen haben corona überlagert
alles die neue familienministerin wird
fürs impfen auch von kindern meine
persönliche meinung ist dass ich allen
familien eltern nur raten kann dass sie
sich informieren und das sich
hoffentlich auch entscheiden ihre kinder
dann impfen zu lassen denn insgesamt das
wissen wir ja alle je mehr geimpfte
viren und der gesellschaft haben desto
besser können wir dieser pandemie auch
die stirn bieten wurzeln für die zukunft
es ist ein etwas rätselhaftes motto das
sich die grünen minister gegeben haben
dabei ist noch offen wie gut diese
grünen wurzeln am ende das regieren mit
rot und gelb vertragen werden
inmitten einer weltweiten
gesundheitskrise die regierungsgeschäfte
zu übernehmen wird jedenfalls kein
vergnügen werden zumal die lage in
deutschland so übel ist am schlimmsten
in sachsen der landtag hat deshalb heute
die epidemische lage festgestellt die
landesweite incidents in sachsen liegt
bei über 1200
zugleich ist in sachsen der anteil von
corona verharmlosen bis hin zu radikalen
leugnern besonders hoch dass sachsens
kliniken am anschlag sind dass patienten
ausgeflogen werden müssen ärzteschaft
und pflegepersonal total erschöpft sind
dass operationen abgesagt werden nichts
davon scheint in das bewusstsein der zu
bringen die sich gegen jede ein
dämmungsmaßnahmen wären wie viel gewalt
potenzial steckt in diesem chor ohne
protesten dazu gleich noch ein gespräch
doch zunächst berichtet cornelia
schiemenz aus sachsen
in freiberg spazieren sie heute abend
wieder das klingt harmlos aber es ist
protest gegen die korona maßnahmen und
ein verstoß gegen geltendes recht wir
haben heute beispielsweise auch pfiffe
gehört mehrfach und auch vereinzelte
sprechchöre insofern sehen wir das schon
hier als versammlung und werden hier für
diese personen einen verstoß gegen die
krone notfallverordnung fertigen wegen
der teilnahme an einer versammlung es
sind die freien sachsen die die proteste
im ganzen freistaat orchestrieren und
radikalisieren über den messenger dienst
telegramm melden sie spaziergänge an in
bis zu 80 orten gleichzeitig und spielen
dabei katz und maus mit der polizei die
freien sachsen oder der politische
gegner der sächsischen regierung sorgt
natürlich über die sozialen medien mit
fake news mit bild und die waren nicht
beweisen kann und darauf müssen wir uns
ja immer mehr einstellen es sind
menschen die angst haben sich impfen zu
lassen händler die um ihre existenz
bangen unter den corona protestlern sind
aber auch immer mehr knallharte
extremisten mitglieder bei den freien
sachsen beobachtet vom sächsischen
verfassungsschutz bei telegramm finden
sich immer wieder mord aufrufe der
gehört vor ein militärgericht und
erschossen kretzschmar gehört mit
sofortiger wirkung an die wand
kopfschuss auf offener straße
dahinter sind natürlich auch
grundlegende skepsis
gegenüber dem was im land oder bund in
der politik gemacht wird und die
menschen trauen der politik den
institutionen und zum teil eben auch der
demokratie nicht so wichtig über den weg
der sächsischen landtag hat in einer
sondersitzung die epidemische notlage
festgestellt damit sind weitere
verschärfungen möglich der fackel
aufmarsch vor dem privathaus von petra
köpping hat viele aufgerüttelt es gibt
solidaritätsbekundungen an die
sozialministerin und das strikte
versprechen sachsen werde handeln
eindeutig als solche zu bezeichnende
versuch der einschüchterung und das
dürfen wir uns nicht gefallen lassen
das lassen wir uns nicht gefallen petra
köpping sie haben unsere
hundertprozentige solidarität
unterstützung so lassen wir nicht
miteinander umgehen der fackel aufmarsch
war ein angriff auf die demokratie
diese einsicht ist da die frage ist
welches handeln daraus in sachsen und
resultiert aber
entsprechen mit dem soziologen und
extremismusforscher professor matthias
quendt direktor des instituts für
demokratie und zivilgesellschaft in
jeder guten abend herr professor kennt
guten abend russland klar wenn wir noch
mal zurück gucken auf den freitag einen
fackel aufmarsch vor dem privaten
wohnhaus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin da sieht man ja so
aus wie so eine spontan ausbrechende
bürgerwut aber spontan dürfte daran
ziemlich wenig sein oder wie schätzen
sie das ein das war nicht spontan man
konnte in telegramm kanälen ablesen dass
hiervon schon seit wochen dafür geworben
wird die privatadressen von
politikerinnen und politikern zu sammeln
um dann dort vor ort aktionen
durchzuführen das war nicht in bezug auf
frau kipping unbedingt vorhersehbar aber
doch in hinblick auf die aktionsform
vorhersehbar das war ein orchestrierte
organisierter aufmarsch man ist mit
autos angereist aus verschiedenen
regionen insofern der die spontaneität
des bürgerprotestes ist in wirklichkeit
eine ziemlich kalt geplante
rechtsradikale form sich aufmerksamkeit
zu verschaffen und politische
gegnerinnen einzuschüchtern also sie
sehen hier auch den unmittelbaren
zusammenhang zwischen rechtsradikalismus
und rechtsextremismus und diesem corona
thema das da gespielt wird sozusagen
natürlich fast flächendeckend in
ostdeutschland sind rechtsextreme
akteure sowohl bei der organisation aber
auch bei der inhaltlichen prägung dieser
proteste enorm einflussreich das
betrifft insbesondere auch sachsen mit
den sogenannten freien sachsen das sind
dieselben akteure die vor drei jahren in
chemnitz gegen die unterbringung von
geflüchteten menschen demonstriert haben
die bei peter demonstriert haben das ist
kein zufall das ist auch keine spontane
eruption sondern das ist eine
aufgestaute ein gesammeltes und auch ein
verhärtet das milieu des
rechtsradikalismus dass sich im grunde
seit 2013 auch so herausgebildet und
etabliert hat und das jetzt noch mal ein
neues thema entdeckt hat mit der korona
pandemie mit der besorgniserregenden
entwicklung dass es ihnen damit gelingt
über das eigene rechte klientel das ja
schon groß genug ist gerade auch in
sachsen und anderen ostdeutschen
bundesländern aber nicht nur da über
dieses milieu hinaus zu wirken eben es
ist das fällt ja auf einen fruchtbaren
boden das sind ja nicht nur eine
handvoll akteure
das sind nicht nur eine handvoll akteure
und es ist ja auch nicht nur der
rechtsextremen rand der im moment hier
den zusammenhalt auf die probe stellt
wenn die bild zeitung gegen für gegen
führende wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zu fehde führt sie den
chip stores im internet und auch im
realen leben preisgibt wenn wir diskurse
haben die egoismus mit freiheit
verwechseln dann ist doch die frage
umgehen den zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft und auch um die frage der
randständigkeit bestimmte position noch
mal neu gestellt und auch der umgang
oder besser gesagt der polizeiliche
nicht umgang mit vielen der sogenannten
spaziergängen die jetzt gegen die neuen
maßnahmen der neuen welle der korona
pandemie stattfinden die müssen in
diesem kontext betrachtet werden und das
ist sozusagen auch ein ein zentrales
politisches
defizit in der mitte hier mit nicht
umzugehen das einfach frei laufen zu
lassen auch das nicht vorher gesehen zu
haben obwohl es seit jahren sichtbar ist
wie diese radikalisierung in den
sozialen medien befeuert wird aber eben
nicht nur dort sie sprachen uns gerade
den die plattform telegramm an und der
sich offenbar viele aus dieser szene
besonders gerne tummeln das müsste doch
eigentlich auch strafrechtlich relevant
sein wenn da aufgerufen wird
privatadressen zu sammeln oder mit mit
mord und totschlag gedroht wird der wird
mit mord und totschlag gedroht er wird
auch mit mit mit aufstand mit revolution
mit nürnberger prozessen gedroht und
zwar auch unter klarnamen es ist kein
problem von anonymisierung es ist ein
problem davon dass schlicht keine
rechtsdurchsetzung stattfindet aber
faktisch findet diese rechtsdurchsetzung
ja auch auf den straßen nicht statt das
heißt also dieses spektrum führt den
start an der nase herum die polizei hat
in vielen regionen auch heute wieder der
dieses treiben lassen obwohl sie gegen
auflagen verstoßen obwohl sie sich nicht
an die regeln halten und das befeuert
natürlich eine radikalisierung wenn man
immer wieder bestätigung bekommt wenn
man sich immer wieder zeigt dass man
stärker oder vermeintlich schlauer ist
als der verhasste staat dann führt das
dazu dass der zulauf immer größer wird
nicht nur auf telegramm sondern hat auch
auf den straßen und das ist das problem
sagt der extremismusforscher matthias
quendt ich danke ihnen sehr für das
gespräch denn
das interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
nachher im heute-journal update gibt es
zu dem thema noch ein gespräch mit dem
oberbürgermeister der stadt grimma dort
wohnt die sächsische
gesundheitsministerin vor deren haus der
fackel aufmarsch stattfand professor
kennt hat es eben schon angesprochen
der hass der korona leugner und anderer
querdenker richtet sich nicht nur gegen
politiker sondern auch gegen
wissenschaftler mit dem thema beginnt
die nachrichten von gundula gause der
wissenschaftsrat der bund und länder im
bereich der forschung berät kritisiert
die einseitige berichterstattung gegen
wissenschaftler wie zuletzt in der bild
zeitung es sei diffamierend auf welche
weise einzelne forschende zur schau
gestellt und persönlich für dringend
erforderliche aber unpopuläre maßnahmen
zur pandemie bekämpfung verantwortlich
gemacht würden und gegen diesen beitrag
der bild zeitung legte die berliner
humboldt-universität beschwerde beim
presserat ein das robert koch institut
meldete 27 1836 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden
1528 weniger als vor einer woche 81
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
inzidenz stieg leicht auf 4
141,9 in myanmar ist die gestürzte
regierungschef in sun tzu chi von einem
militärgericht schuldig gesprochen
worden unter anderem wegen aufwiegelung
zu protesten die haftstrafe von vier
jahren wurde auf zwei jahre halbiert un
beobachter bezeichnen das verfahren als
einen scheinprozess
die friedensnobelpreisträgerin hatte im
herbst letzten jahres die wiederwahl zur
regierungschefin klar gewonnen das
militär wüste viele sitze ein machte
massiven betrug geltend und putschte
seitdem gibt es immer wieder proteste
gegen das militärregime
österreich hat einen neuen bundeskanzler
karl hammer der designierte chef der
konservativen övp ist vereidigt worden
der 49-jährige nähe hammer war zuvor
innenminister seine ernennung zum
regierungschef geht mit einer
kabinettsumbildung einher die hammers
vorgänger alexander schallenberg
übernimmt wieder das amt des
außenministers hintergrund ist der
rückzug von sebastian kurz aus der
politik der frühere bundeskanzler hatte
wegen korruptionsermittlungen den
rückhalt in der övp verloren
trotz der korona pandemie haben
rüstungskonzerne im vergangenen jahr
ihre umsätze erneut gesteigert das
sechste jahr in folge wie das
stockholmer friedensforschungsinstitut
sipri ermittelt hat demnach setzten die
100 größten hersteller insgesamt 470
milliarden euro um das ist ein plus von
1,3 prozent im vergleich zu 2009 10
spitzenreiter bleiben die usa die vier
deutschen rüstungsunternehmen auf der
liste verkauften waffen im wert von
knapp 7,9 milliarden euro
wichtigster rüstungskontrolle lanz
bleibt indien präsident putin kündigte
bei seinem staatsbesuch in neu delhi
eine noch stärkere militärische
zusammenarbeit an beim treffen mit
premier modi bezeichnete putin indien
als einen bewährten freund beide länder
vereinbarten verschiedene
rüstungsprojekte unter anderem sollen
600.000 russische sturmgewehr in indien
hergestellt werden außerdem sollen
russland
raketenabwehrsysteme für mehrere
milliarden us dollar liefern
und was hat russland mit der ukraine vor
die frage stellt sich dem westen immer
drängender insbesondere die amerikaner
wollen dass of moscow mehr druck
ausgeübt wird
dass putin sozusagen die folterwerkzeuge
gezeigt werden was ihn erwartet sollte
er im wahrsten sinne des wortes die
grenze überschreiten morgen wird es
zudem einen video gipfel zwischen dem
russischen und dem amerikanischen
präsidenten geben als so freundlich
dürfte der ton dabei nicht sein für
heuer neu hand berichtet
die vielleicht schärfste waffe des
westens gegen russland versteckt sich
hinter bäumen vor den toren brüssels
trifft das wichtigste zahlungssystem ein
land hiervon abzukoppeln das wäre
sozusagen eu-diplomaten die nukleare
option denkbar auch gegenüber russland
dann würde der zugang zu internationalen
zahlungsströmen weitgehend gekappt das
wäre natürlich
ökonomisch eine sehr einschneidende
maßnahme und deswegen bin ich der
meinung es muss auf den tisch legen es
ist die frage dieser tage was tun wenn
russland tatsächlich die ukraine
angreift womit drohen damit das gar
nicht erst passiert von der gefahr haben
die usa ihre nato partner offenbar
überzeugen können jetzt geht es um die
öffentlichkeit termin bei der neuen us
botschafterin bei der nato erst wenige
tage im amt hat sie gleich eine mission
warnen ohne konkret zu werden
wir glauben dass russland einen großen
schlag gegen die ukraine in den
kommenden wochen plant
was wäre denn dann die konsequenz
ich glaube nicht dass washington bereit
ist diese optionen öffentlich zu
diskutieren
nur so viel wir prüfen dinge die bisher
noch nicht auf dem tisch sind sanktionen
mit einschneidenden wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen
in den kommenden wochen werden sie davon
noch mehr hören
erst mal aber hört und sieht der westen
wie russland militärisch mit den säbeln
rasseln und politisch rote linien zieht
vor dem video gipfel mit us-präsident
beiden hier bilder vom letzten treffen
im juni lässt putin seinen sprecher
ausrichten
man wird über die sicherheitsgarantien
reden müssen wie putin gefordert hatte
keine nato osterweiterung
russland fühlt sich betrogen vom westen
erinnert an einen deutschen
außenminister der einst versprach
das was immerhin war verpackt geschieht
nicht beabsichtigt ist die nato nach
osten auszudehnen nur die vermeintliche
zusage stand in keinem vertrag wie
historiker heute betonen es gibt nichts
höflichen und im gegenteil was ist
schlüssig es gibt erlaubt die nato
erlaubt es die nato die ehemalige
freundin wir hier vom kalten krieg zu
überqueren und moskau hat diesen vertrag
unterzeichnet auf eine neue zusage
dürfte moskau also morgen vergeblich
warten wie auch die us-botschafterin
heute betont
russland spielt bei dieser entscheidung
keine rolle und hat kein vetorecht die
beiden nato-erweiterung in welcher form
auch immer
derweil bereitet der westen offenbar die
schärfsten sanktionen vor russland vom
zahlungsverkehr abzuschneiden in der
hoffnung dass allein die drohung schon
wirkt
mit wirtschaft geht es weiter und die
finanzmärkte schauen mit sorge auf den
chinesischen immobilienkonzerne brand
der konzern steckt seit monaten hoch
verschuldet in einer schweren krise
berichte über mögliche zahlungsausfälle
im rahmen von kredit umstrukturierungen
ließen die ihre grand aktie an der
hongkonger börse zu diesem wochenstart
um 20 prozent auf ein rekordtief fallen
chinesische behörden haben nun amtliche
überprüfungen in der konzernzentrale in
shenzen angeordnet im zuge der evergreen
krise hat ein weiterer
immobilienentwickler in china
schuldenprobleme auch das unternehmen
sun shine kann dort seine millionen
kredite nicht bedienen das belastet auch
den deutschen markt ebenso wie der
deutliche rückgang der aufträge für die
deutsche industrie im oktober sanken die
bestellungen um 6,9 prozent gegenüber
dem vormonat meldet das statistische
bundesamt stefanie und auch hier zeigt
sich die abhängigkeit von china auf
jeden fall bei genauerer betrachtung
achtung geht er doch überraschend
deutliche rückgang deutscher industrie
aufträge vor allem auf das konto von
china denn in asien sorgt derzeit die
virus welle für erneute lockt downs und
das bremst die industrie hierzulande aus
allein 18 prozent weniger großaufträge
zogen deutsche maschinenbauer im oktober
aus übersee an land aus dem euroraum
gingen gut drei prozent weniger aufträge
ein zulegen konnten allein die
bestellungen im inland seit mai 20 20
hatte die deutsche industrie einen
schier ungebremsten lauf und sie sitzt
derzeit immer noch auf prall gefüllten
auftragsbüchern die sie nach und nach
abarbeiten der flaschenhals sind
weiterhin materialengpässe und die
lieferketten schwierigkeiten das wissen
auch kunden und sie stellen
möglicherweise deshalb den einen oder
anderen auftrag auch zurück dieser
winter könnte also noch unberechenbar
für die deutsche industrie werden denn
sie ist der virus welle auch finanziell
ungeschützte ausgesetzt hier in
frankfurt verlor heute die virusvariante
omikron etwas von ihrem schrecken
anleger fassten wieder mut und der dax
schloss zum wochenauftakt mit einem
kräftigen plus von über 200 punkten
kauflaune auch an der wall street wie es
scheint haben die anleger die hoffnung
auf eine weihnachtsrallye doch noch
nicht aufgegeben vielen dank stefanie
bareth
us präsident biden hat seine drohung
wahrgemacht das weiße haus verkündete
den diplomatischen boykott der
olympischen winterspiele in peking die
beiden regierungen werde keine
diplomaten oder offiziellen vertreter zu
den spielen entsenden grund seien die
anhaltenden menschenrechtsverletzungen
in china die us sportler aber sollen
reisen nach ihrem intensiven training
sollten sie nicht durch einen kompletten
boykott bestraft werden in indonesien
erschwert ein erneuter ausbruch des
vulkans simyo die suche nach
überlebenden
einsatzkräfte mussten sich
zwischenzeitlich zurückziehen als der
vulkan wieder ein dutzend dörfer auf der
insel java in asche die zahl der
todesopfer stieg auf 22 vermisst werden
noch 27 menschen der vulkan auf java war
am samstag ausgebrochen
tausende häuser wurden beschädigt
indonesien liegt auf dem sogenannten
pazifischen feuerring und hat rund 130
aktive vulkane
das was von uns gleich gehts mit dem zdf
montagskino weiter heute mit dem detlev
buck film wir können nicht anders und
direkt danach gegen 23 55 meldet sich
wulf schmiese mit unserem heute-journal
update auf wiedersehen bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend heute möchte ich ihre
aufmerksamkeit auf diese hochs und tiefs
lenken und wie sie ziehen das geld
nämlich zieht vor allen dingen nach
norden das hochseil richtung gewesen und
das -tief harry nach osten dass die
harry ist ein ganz besonderes tief wir
sprechen von einer rapiden cyclo genese
manchmal spricht man auch von einer
bombe genese weil dieses tief sich zu
einem orkantief ausbildet die
kräftigsten windgeschwindigkeiten gibt
es wohl morgen abend im mittel
orkanstärke 120 kilometer pro stunde und
in böen durchaus über 150 kilometer pro
stunde dieses orkantief wird zwar
irgendwann auch in mitteleuropa ankommen
aber doch deutlich abgeschwächt und auch
erst einen tag später aktuell haben wir
uns nämlich noch mit dem tief garrett zu
tun und mit dem schnee und regen wolken
die jetzt in der nacht von westen heran
ziehen bis zum frühen morgen erreichen
sie etwa hamburg und münchen gefährlich
bleibt kann es aber eigentlich überall
werden bei tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
plus 3 und minus neun grad über schnee
am alpenrand und morgen bleibt es kalt
im nordosten mit minus 1 grad deutlich
milder wird es am oberrhein mit sieben
grad und auch morgen kann es noch schnee
regen und schneefälle geben zwischen
schleswig holstein und dem alpenrand das
lässt über tag mehr und mehr nach und
dann sehen wir auch häufiger mal die
sonne zum beispiel in sachsen aber auch
im westen und an den alpen gefährlich
wird es dann wieder am mittwoch mit
neuen schnee und schneeregen wolken in
bayern und in baden württemberg das
reicht etwa bis nach thüringen und
winterlich geht es danach auch weiter
guten abend